à san franciso externe qui nous attend
depuis un petit moment maintenant
directe d'essence bonsoir et merci
d'avoir patienté votre réaction mardi
soir donc réélu ce soir à sens votre
commentaire
bah je la félicite évidemment puisque ce
sont les électeurs qui ont décidé
qu'elle soit le prochain maire de sens
je revendique clairement je vous ai
entendu tout à l'heure par l'absence
d'étiquette s'arrêter qu'à partir
l'aider sans étiquette donc moi je
revendique clairement ce positionnement
sans étiquette politique
ce positionnement je les construis
depuis plusieurs mois avec des personnes
qui ont sont ont été autour de moi dans
cette liste du bon sens de des personnes
de droite de gauche du centre et j'ai eu
l'habitude de dire que j'étais ni de
droite ni de gauche que j'étais devant
aujourd'hui effectivement je suis
derrière marie louise fort mais avec 33
pour presque 33 % des 2 2 voies avec
2700 personnes qui est derrière moi se
sont reconnus dans un projet qui était
basée sur l'intérêt général
un projet où le plus important était
laissée donné les celanese aujourd'hui
manifestement c'est encore difficile
dans une ville de 25000 habitants de de
gagner la mairie sans étiquette
politique le poids des partis est encore
prépondérant le poids de l'ump a été
important dans cette élection le poids
du fn également voilà aujourd'hui je
suis fier d'avoir conduit avec l'équipe
qui m'entoure est depuis plusieurs mois
cette cette aventure je sais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est possible de vous
faire de la politique autrement de la
politique basée sur l'intérêt général
sur le souci de répondre aux problèmes
des habitants et des habitantes et je
continue cet engagement parce que je
sais qu'il répond à à une majorité des
décès monnaies cenonnaise je sais aussi
que c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen de
ré de réconcilier les habitants avec la
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui à sens il
ya presque 40 9 % d'abstentionnistes et
ça n'est pas marie louise fort a été élu
avec la moitié des voix le car même avec
25% des des suffrages des habitants donc
on ne peut pas se réjouir de ce taux
d'abstention aussi important mais